the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alrighty so we're back we're going to do
the examples for the you just sort of
described in the previous notes and
again once again these are in the you
have your deform directory here they're
in examples applications by a blast this
shows you the two programs are going to
run we do have two examples and then
we're going to be comparing two pieces
of actual data so if you look at this
this shows you you know what what that
data looks like so sequence ID and then
very long long sequences here and not
all they it be sure nice if they were
all the same length but they certainly
are not the same length you know they
vary dramatically here you can see you
know which probably one that's dead look
at that guy what's he doing super long
so this is a this is a reference
bacteria dataset this is known data and
this is a sequence here of some data
taken from somebody's Paul this is open
source data not and so yeah so this just
example of that and so you can imagine
one would want to do a comparison of the
data you know of what the DNA sequences
on the bacteria on the person's and are
with some reference data set so
obviously we are not going to be using a
data set this is a very small data set
here we're not going to be able to do
probably we won't expect to have any
matches here and we're not going to have
any but this just shows you kind of how
that works so here and so the first one
here was this BB one it's just basically
alrighty so what we've done is we set
our word size we're going to use 10
sequence 10 base pairs so that's what
we're basically dealing with 10 verse
and wrote a little program here that
what it does is given a csv file fasta
file and a word sides it then creates
the associative array as we described so
basically each sequence will be a row so
for instance we'll get into that and
likewise each 10 mer will then be a
column and so we do this for the two
datasets here is our matrix multiply so
a1 times a 2 transpose gives us a 1 a 2
and here is our pedigreed matrix
multiply the cat kamal a 1 a 2 transpose
and gives us a 1 a 2 key and so we can
now look at that so a 1 198 that's the
bacteria at 198 sequences with eight
thousand and one unique 10 verse a two
had thousand sequences with 20 365
unique 10 murs and then when you matrix
multiply them you see that 85 195 and
the reference had a match with 415 of
the 999 in the sample so we're losing
about half in each case because the
associative array does not store empty
values there's going to be no key which
is an empty as an empty row completely
empty row or completely empty column so
we can now look at those at data so if
we look at figure 1 here so this is the
this is a 1 so this shows you again here
when we zoom in right
so that gives you a better sense of the
structure can actually click on that so
here's you know here's a 10 mer that
appears in an awful lot of things so
basically this 10 Merc peers an awful
lot of things you know in years these
are examples of you know yours here's a
row corresponding to a particular
particular sequence ID so that's a one
that's the reference a to the sample
pretty much the same type of thing
although a little bit different
structure more of these dense things
maybe zoom in on one of these blobs here
see those time flip-flops there I got
this guy who's he this guy begins with
GCC AC and GCC TT and other types of
things there and this this is the cross
so if we go now to figure 3 this is the
cross correlation of all those and it
holds the count so you can see here one
you know one most of these are just 11
and unless I did some kind of threshold
antifa that were larger and then figure
four years our pedigreed multiplication
so now it shows you what the actual so
this tells us that this sequence ID and
this you know so this reference sequence
ID and this sample sequence ID had a
match at this 10 mer
there we go so we go back here and as we
see as I clicked on that it printed out
the full sequence so if you wanted to
ever like just do a cut and paste and
then put this in something else so like
if I want to look at this row you know I
could then do a 1 and that gives me that
row you know and I can do other things
you know I could do like all right let's
sum that you know if it's something the
columns up that tells me they're 138
unique sequences in that and that
sequence ID so those types of things
there right so I think we pretty much
covered that yep and so now we'll go on
to the next example and I apologize this
takes a little bit longer to run because
now I'm doing two things when i read in
the data i'm doing the same thing I did
before in terms of sensing I want 10
verse but I'm going to read the data
again the slightly different function
and it can return to associate or is
this associative array was that was the
same as before which showed us the
actual counts how many times if you had
a ten mirror and it counted the next one
gives us a concatenated list of the
positions so we're so if it appeared
five times will actually show us you
know hold that information a list of the
five location you know is in the greater
sequence which then allows us to do
those things I talked about before so
this takes a minute to do that probably
with some optimization I've no doubt
that this could be could be made major
it faster and also with the
video recording going on a lot of lot of
pressure on this personal computer
just some additional information here in
terms of the whose command you know so
we basically do who's a to show me all
the different associative arrays I have
so you can see on this tallies up the
bikes that are associated so our first
associative array as you saw was about
seven hundred kilobytes and that
basically adds up all the data steward
in all the data structures inside it
usually does a pretty good job of that
likewise and as you can see there's a
significant reduction in the total size
of that and in this case we didn't
really add that much by adding the keys
you know so this is a very nice data set
for us to do our cat chemo lon there was
no dents diagonal or anything like that
to get in our way there so that was that
was a very useful thing to have around
at least these were now in the second
read so almost there
and being able to click on the thing
actually printed out is because when we
actually do the spy plot in this case it
works out pretty well because our our
keys are relatively short but we do
truncate that so if you have a rocky or
column key that's very long when we do
the plots we truncate that and then you
would never actually know what the true
full string was so right just about
finish there alrighty so again we read
in the data and now I wanted to make a
degree distribution of the data so just
like we did our degree distributions
earlier this is a great way to get a
sense of the overall statistics all
right so I took 1a 1n the way I do that
is I have the associative array a 1 by
do the adj or adjacency matrix I think
this basically just pops out the
internal sparse matrix that's stored
okay and now i can do regular math on
that and we happen to have this little
built-in function called out degree
which essentially does you know on the
out direction the appropriate sums and
returns a sparse matrix which we can
then plot in this log log form so this
is the this is the reference this is the
reference data you see as this
distribution here which is very power
law like although as we saw on your list
classes unless we properly fit and bin
this we wouldn't really know if this was
a power law or something like it but
probably our first order linear fit of a
power law would be at least a good place
to start as it usually is with this data
there's the other one would appear to be
even more power law like but again until
we Bennett we don't really know what
happens
we start bidding this stuff up here
maybe it will blow up in some way maybe
it won't mom probably would probably
would look more like this um a question
for you or good question is you know I
showed you that other data set and it
didn't look like this you know you saw
this you saw very kind of almost a log
normal gaussian distribution and you
might as well what because of the same
data you know it's still 10 murder type
of data and so the only difference is
the size and so when you have ten murs
you have since each one can be you have
four choices of letter all right you
essentially have two million total
possible 10 murs so in this data set in
fact we can count here right we do a one
for you n + Z we only have two hundred
and seventy four thousand entries so
we're not fully sampling the two million
possibilities here the other day to set
that database was actually 500 million
entries and so we're really fully
sampling and so you're getting you know
just this basically what's happening is
you know these guys are rare they don't
show up you know and they start getting
you know more you're hitting them once
and eventually begin to create this sort
of more Gaussian distribution look or
bell curve look when you when you start
fully sampling I don't that's generally
true or not but I you one could
hypothesize that a lot of the data and
is just a guess a lot of the day that we
see is power law is because we're not
fully sampling the total space that
emerges or that total space is growing
at a rate as we sample it so like domain
names we haven't fully sampled the
entire space of domain names in the
main the set of domain names in the
internet continues to grow at a fairly
significant rate now maybe one day there
will stop being new domain names and
then when we start doing our sampling
maybe our distribution zondo name domain
names won't look so power lauding more
but more like a log normal distribution
with a kind of a bell bell shape just to
hypothesis but certainly many data we
have you know don't do that now of
course the easiest way for me to changes
instead of doing 10 MERS would it be to
do 20 MERS now I've dramatically
increased the space of possibilities and
so the odds of having just statistical
matches start piling up are very very
low so that is certainly something that
people do too and and in the case for
the calculation we were doing we just
got lucky we actually did not think 10
mer would be the right sampling for that
data we thought it would be a higher
number like a 15 or 20 mer and it turns
out that Enver was just actually spot on
terms of giving us this nice balance
between sampling but statistical power
that we could eliminate more more common
occurrences all right so we plotted the
outdegree again a very useful technique
one should always do these basic you
know understand the overall statistics
of one's data we're doing the same cross
correlation here that we did before
except since in that previous data set
the value didn't store the account that
was very fast read we just had a you
know all the values were one here we
actually have a count and so we don't
really care that you know we don't want
it the case in this particular
correlation we don't care if like well
this tenma appeared 10 times in this one
sequence and appeared three times in
this other sequence and when we multicam
them together we get a 30 that's not
really what we're really more interested
in like you know how many unique ones
did they each have how many distinct
ones did we each have so we use the
double og function to basically convert
all our numbers back to just zeros and
ones and then do that correlation again
and then here we do the and since the
values don't matter when we do the cap
chemo we don't need to do that and then
we do the same correlation and so here
we are we're finding the sequences with
with that have a greater than eight
match here actually doing some fairly
inside tricks here to do that you might
as what is this put so it's fairly clear
what I'm doing here right I'm taking
this count I'm saying please return the
sub associative array of all things with
greater than a value of eight more than
eight matches all right that's good then
I'm flooring that I'm saying make that
all you know just once all right and
then I'm doing this trick here which is
called put Val and I'm giving it this
random string well when I do that so
right now this is just an associate rate
without a value when I put that thing in
there since all my things have a value
of one and I'll have one string it's now
saying you know what I've just made all
those values tilde like why on earth
would we do that well it's because when
I and them together okay the diff you
know we have to decide what
mathematically when we an to associative
to graze together you recall the lecture
we talked about these collision
functions we have to pick a collision
function for the two strings alright and
this key stores this pedigreed list
which I really want to keep and this
just shows me which ones are the high
match and I don't really care about that
well the default collision function when
in doubt throughout d forum is min so
tilde is LexA graphically after every
other printable character in the
alphabet so when I do a min here i'm
just going to always return the these
values here so there was only one entry
greater than eight and i ended them
together it then
min of Tilda with this whole string here
and it said aha c is less than tilde I'm
just going to give you the sea and so
there we go on so it's an cute it's just
this is just a cute trick but it's a way
of sort of using the collision function
and the group theory that we talked
about in the earlier lectures to get a
very nice you know just selecting the
one that I want here and so that's what
that does and then there you can see so
of these this this sequence ID and this
sequence ID they had eight matches our
greater than eight matches and and this
was the exact 10 verse that actually
matched okay and then we can go back
before and look up those two sequences
compare them side-by-side in the
original data and and then we see these
were the actual positions here and you
would probably look at these well what
do we think here well 137 and 138 that's
right now 139 1 41 41 and then jumping
all the way to 149 so it looks like
those guys are all part of one long
group but then 60 and 172 and 130 are
probably isolated 10 verse and then over
here what do we have we have 111 no but
we do have 119 120 121 122 123 so that's
probably also you know a bigger group
match and so you probably in fact those
all line up with this there there except
for the 149 year but I actually know
some of the match sometime so there's
they're each part of a larger piece but
not not necessarily overlapping in the
same they aren't contiguous with each
other and that's the kind of thing that
people who do this you know then really
look at and of course real match would
be more like something with with many
more sequences this is all just random
randomness
and things like that so alright so
that's the demo um I want to thank you
and again next week tell your friends
who maybe have are not warrant here
today that is the one lecture if you had
to come to one lecture in this entire
class I didn't tell you that as
beginning you notice right because then
you would have skipped the other seven
but no it'll be what we've done before
will really make that allows you that's
the real one and you will then be able
to go when you leave that lecture run
all those examples on those tests
databases that we have there from your
elegant accounts and and have all that
kind of fun and then really and we
really want you to do that because we
released d forum on the web we need
people to test it you know it's much
better if you guys find the issues and
then and then we'll just make it make it
better and likewise it's a step towards
you guys actually using the technology
and then and then in your actual free
actual application so thank you very
much